it won't be awkward until a birthday
invite goes south if you missed it
Dakota Johnson's recent appearance on
The Ellen DeGeneres Show was totally
awkward and had the internet buzzing you
turned 30 I did and how was the party I
wasn't invited after Ellen claimed that
Dakota did invite her to her birthday
party
the actress quickly shut that down
that's not the truth
Ellen you were invited last you know
last time I was on the show last year he
gave me a bunch about not inviting you
but I didn't even know he wanted to be
invited to a party why I didn't even
know you liked me while Ellen continued
to doubt whether she actually received
an invite Dakota got the show producers
to back her up why didn't I go I don't
know was it was it oh yeah I had that
thing fans noticed that thing was
possibly attending the Dallas Cowboys
game where she was seated next to former
president george w bush i didn't plan it
yep it was that fire a moment that had
Twitter buzzing the sighting was so
controversial that Ellen had to address
it on her show later that week people
were upset they thought why is a gay
Hollywood liberal sitting next to a
conservative Republican president people
were mad and they did what people do
when they're mad they tweet and but
here's one tweet that I loved this
person says Ellen and George Bush
together makes me have faith in America
again here's the thing I'm friends with
George Bush in fact I'm friends with a
lot of people who don't share the same
beliefs that I have
[Music]